[Music]
bubbles form spheres because
it is the shape with the lowest surface
area to volume ratio
you couldn't package that air in a more
efficient way
nature is good at working out things
like that quickly
for example if i was to dip this strange
shape here
into some soapy water nature would
figure out how to
span this shape with the soap film
whilst using the least amount of surface
area
quantum computing hopes to piggyback off
this
computational power of nature and i hope
that we can explore this concept a
little bit more today
for this video i've teamed up with
brilliant to show you through
part of a course on quantum computing
it's a course made in collaboration with
microsoft
and alphabet x companies which are
taking quantum computing very seriously
we will work through the nature of
computation quiz
and if by the end of the video you are
still hungry to
learn more about this topic you can sign
up for an account
at brilliant.org tibby's using that link
you can get
20 off a brilliant premium subscription
so welcome to quantum computing
our focus is learning how to exploit the
laws of quantum mechanics
in order to compute so we need to see
the big picture here and we're going to
do that by answering two questions
number one what is the nature of quantum
computing
and number two why do scientists think
it will lead to speed ups on a variety
of
important problems so it says here that
in the dawn of the 20th century
deterministic predictions from classical
mechanics
were failing to explain new experiments
i think i know
one of the things they're talking about
and i have a picture of it here it's the
double slit experiment
and so a new theory was necessary to
describe the results of experiments
performed with quantum objects that's
photons electrons and other microscopic
particles
quantum mechanics foregoes deterministic
predictions
and instead embraces the concept of
probability
so i guess with the double slit
experiment
what's meaningful is the distribution of
all of these particles that you end up
with in the end
but actually the path of any single one
of them
it seems random and doesn't really you
know give you much information it's
the distribution of all of them together
that that leads you to understand what's
going on
all right so we've got classical
mechanics we've got quantum mechanics
and the course says here that we're
going to now go on to play a little bit
of a game
the game that we're going to play is one
that i know as the galton board
although it apparently has other names
the game is a simple
demonstration of how probabilities can
emerge
from a mechanical object so
each bin at the bottom is associated
with a different prize
and the thrill is to watch as your fate
is determined by the random bounces of
the ball of the pegs so you put a ball
down here
it apparently randomly bounces off these
pegs or seems to do so
and lands in one of these bins at the
bottom
that's the way it would classically
happen with a ball and pigs but we're
going to remake it
with our quantum objects our photons it
asks us what is the most
likely outcome of these games and well
choosing from which bin the ball would
land in i would say it would most often
land
in bin number two uh that would be the
middle
just because there are two different
paths that it could take to end up in
number two where there's only one path
to get into bin 1 or bin 3.
with a single photon the quantum game
behaves much like the mechanical version
with the bouncing ball
the more possible paths that lead to a
given outcome
the more likely that it is but if we
shoot
two photons into the top of the grid
things get more interesting
when two or more photons meet somewhere
on the grid
they can interfere with one another
interference can lead to anything from
the two
photons adding constructively and
appearing like two photons
or cancelling each other out entirely as
if there were no photons at all
yeah thanks to this interference we
don't have any better way to find where
the photons will most likely
end up than to trace out all the paths
each photon can take and calculate the
interference effects
where they meet so we can't just add up
the paths like we would do classically
so what we're concerned with here is
that to predict the
end state of a quantum object we need to
account for
all the paths it could have taken to get
there
and so how difficult is it to
computationally predict
the outcomes of this quantum game in
just this most
simple example where we're putting in
two photons and we have
two rows of beam splitters then each
photon
can take one of four paths leading to
16 different total combinations of paths
and that's 16 different interference
calculations that we would need to do
obviously as the game gets larger with
more photons or just
more rows of beam splitters it's going
to get a lot more complicated
it tells us here that calculating the
interference for each path combination
is not too hard it takes tc
seconds and it asks us how much time
does it take to calculate the photon
distribution
for a three layer quantum game with two
photons
so we need to figure out how many total
path combinations there
are and then times that by t c to find
out how long this calculation would take
us
for two rows we had 16 path combinations
and for three rows we're going to have
more than
16 because there is more possible paths
that can be taken
so i'm going to put in 64 tc
as my answer to how long this is going
to take all right so instead of doing
all of those calculations the question
is what if we just
build this thing so if we had a beam
splitter we can just shoot
two photons into the top and use photon
counters to find the distribution at the
bottom experimentally instead of even
trying to work out the distribution
so for each measurement the sampling
time
would be equal to the time the photons
take to traverse the gap
l from the first beam splitter to the
row of photon counters at the speed of
light
for a single beam splitter with two
detectors like this one here
this photon sampling time takes a time
t q so the question is how much time
does it take
for a three layer experimental solve of
this quantum game
all right so if t q is how long it takes
the photons to go from there
to there this looks like it's just three
times as much so i would go
for three times tq
so how long will a photon counting
measurement and an in layer game take
experimentally so if we had n layers
that would just be n times t q
i think the idea here is that n times t
q
is increasing a lot less quickly than
our computational one our two to the two
n yeah so the time required in these two
different methods computational and
experimental
are increasing at different rates as the
number of layers of n increases
our classical computation is increasing
exponentially with
n whereas our quantum experiment is
increasing
only linearly with n this is because the
quantum objects in the experiment have
no
obligation to compute every path
according to the rules of quantum
mechanics like we're trying to do with
our computer
they obey quantum mechanics as a matter
of course it's
just what nature does if we assign a
time
to tq from our quantum experiment and tc
from our computational one even though
tc
is lower than tq we can see visually
down here
what is really going to start to happen
so for
a low number of rows in our experiment
it is quicker to you know just do it
classically
to just figure it out you know if
there's less than about 10 rows we can
just do some maths
and work out the interference paths in a
pretty quick time
but once you get up to about 11 12
layers deep
it's really going up exponentially and
it's starting to take you
ages each time to calculate all these
paths
whereas the quantum experiment which is
just going up linearly
although at the start it would take you
a little bit longer to do it through the
experiment
in the long run it will be much much
quicker
with the language we've been using it's
been kind of obvious that the classical
approach is occurring on an actual
computer whereas the quantum approach we
could believe it's happening in kind of
a lab
experiment set up but actually because
it says here both methods produce the
same information so if one is a
computation
so is the other the basic truth of
what's happening in quantum computing
is that we're directly employing quantum
objects
to perform a specific computation
to whatever extent we can map and mold
our computational problem
onto quantum objects we'll be able to
use it to our advantage
if a problem has an inherent quantum
aspect to it
like finding the interference pattern
then we could expect
a quite big speed up this problem
was really hard to compute on a
classical computer because the resources
that it requires
grow exponentially as n increases but i
like the way they say it here
it is quite easy to compute quantumly
with an experiment and i think that's
basically what our
quantum computer is doing it's it's not
an experiment in a lab like we might
think with a galton board and
beam splitters and and things like that
but we're
mapping our problem onto quantum objects
and kind of exploiting that way of
nature
to try and do things quicker to take
things back to where we started off the
video we can take a little look at this
green sculpture here which i think is
really cool
and it is made of these big metal
circles with a green fabric draped
between them
so the shape we see here in the picture
is apparently ideal in this way it is
impossible to find
any other such smooth shape that
contacts the metal rings
while using any less material all right
so this is an
optimized sculpture to figure out things
like this
so to find this surface this green
surface computationally
is quite involved and requires
algorithms built on sophisticated
mathematics
the quiz asks us here is there an easier
way to work it out
and which phenomenon might be able to
compute
this surface in real time using the laws
of physics
well if we go back to the start of the
video
i used a soap bobble a soap bubble
always minimizes the surface area
so you can have a little look on this
page
yeah natural systems like soap bubbles
have a tendency to
wiggle around until they minimize their
energy
minimization problems make up so much of
physics
and you might have encountered them in
problems before
things like the principle of least
action trying to
i guess minimize the action on a path
that an object would take
for a soap film the energy is equal to
its total surface area times its surface
tension so this is basically the energy
required to keep the layer of soap
stretched out here's another picture of
dipping a spring into the soap and this
soap goes all the way around the fingers
as well
there's your answer from nature and
here's your answer
from an actual classical computer as
well i could try to use
quite a complicated shape one that is
definitely very difficult
to find the spanning surface area
computationally nature however
still gives me this answer instantly and
it's
really fascinating so you might consider
the
computational power of soapy water to be
essentially zero
but if you have a very unique problem to
solve it can be far
superior to a modern computer i guess
quantum computing
is a bit about trying to make humans as
clever as soapy water
we would like to piggyback nature to
perform our calculation
for us so in a real sense quantum
computers
do not compute at all but simply carry
on according to the laws of physics
the extent to which quantum computing
can revolutionize computation
depends on us finding ways to restate
computational problems in equivalent
quantum systems
i think this kind of makes me realize
that quantum computing is not
really just a magical increase in
all of the normal computing that we do
and all of the normal problems that we
try to solve on computers
but it's rather coming at computing from
a different angle and it's going to be
up to us
to be able to map our problems into the
quantum world so that we can take
advantage of quantum computing
but it's all very clever and it also
makes you realize how clever
nature is itself that you know nature
can calculate these things so instantly
on on such a grand scale
and i don't know if we really have any
idea how it happens
i hope that you learned a thing or two
in this video today
and thank you for watching